Hi guys, very good morning. My name is Athef Hassan and I am a PhD student at the AI department
of IIT Kharagpur. So we will be going over the hands-on session now for BERT. So as Sir
has already talked about the BERT model, now we will be going over the hands-on session
and see how things are actually coded in the real world.
So the very first thing that we want to do is, so the very first thing that we want to
do is we want to pip install certain libraries. For example, transformers, torch metrics and
data sets and we will see why this is really important alright. So the transformers library
is from Hugging Face. It provides you all the latest transformer models that are available.
In fact a lot of models that have been trained by the community are also available on this
library. So you will find a lot of state of the art models available here. So this is
provided by Hugging Face. Then we have torch metrics. So this library actually provides
us with a lot of classes that allow us to get all the metrics that are required for
classification and other tasks, object detection and so on.
So we do not really need to write our own accuracy metric or precision or F score or
recall metrics. These are already provided in torch metrics and you can just call them
and use it. And pip install data sets, so this allows us to download certain data sets
that are not available on Python as is. So after we have installed these libraries we
will move on. So the first thing that we will do is we will load up the libraries alright.
So now that we have installed them we will load up those libraries but we will also load
a few other libraries such as pandas, numpy, RE stands for regular expression. Then from
the transformers library we want to load the auto tokenizer, birth model, birth for sequence
classification, birth config classes alright.
What TQDM is something that I use personally. It really provides a nice progress bar, a
very nice smooth progress bar which tells you how much time is remaining and what are
the, so what is the speed of each iteration. So you get an idea of how much time your model
will take or your code will take to run. So it is a nice decorative library, I would
recommend people using it and it is very easy to use as well. And we will show it, I will
show it during the coding session. Then there are certain other classes and we will go over
them as we go through the code.
Now the first thing that we want to do is, so before we start off with the code just
one important line here. So device equals to torsion device. So what this does is basically
it tells PyTorch to use either the GPU or the CPU as per the availability. So this is
a very important line of code that I would recommend everyone to have. So you do not
just write torsion device CUDA or you do not just write torsion device CPU, rather you
tell PyTorch that if CUDA is available then use the GPU otherwise use the CPU. So device
automatically takes up whatever device you are going to, whatever device you have on
your computer.
Next up we will go to the pre-processing part of the notebook. So the very, the most important
aspect of any machine learning or any practical machine learning or deep learning situation
is data. So how do you process the data, what kind of data do we have, what to do with that
data, this is extremely important. Because at the end of the day, if you go into the
industry, you will be finding terms like data science. So the word data science itself has
the word data in it. So data is extremely important and how well you process the data
really will provide you with how good a performance you get from a model. Because at the end of
the day, please remember that garbage in is equal to garbage out. This is a very famous
quote in the AI community. So you want to make sure that your model, that your data is as
processed as possible so that all the relationships between the data, between the input and the
target come out so that the model can utilize those relationships and give you the best
of results. So most if not all of your time should be spent on how you improve the data.
Because models are already available and you can download n number of models and utilize
them, but the data part is something that comes from domain knowledge and I recommend
spending as much time as possible on pre-processing the data.
So here we will go over some pre-processing pipeline. So first before we begin with the
pre-processing, what is this notebook about? So in this notebook, we will be going over
the BERT model, but more importantly, the task here is to take IMDB reviews. So what
is IMDB reviews? You probably have heard about the IMDB website, which actually provides
you with ratings and reviews about movies. So what we will do is we will pick up around
25,000 movies and we will try to train and test a model and see what is the sentiment
of those reviews. So why is this important? So just to give some context, the IMDB website,
it provides you with reviews and ratings about movies. So it tells you the sentiment about
a movie, what kind of sentiment people have for a movie and this is really important for
actors and movie directors to understand quickly and even the advertisers as well to understand
quickly how well the movie is performing so that they can change their course of action
based on the sentiment of the movies. Now the problem is that the reviews that are provided,
they have to be manually tagged by someone and there are many, many reviews. So based
on the reviews, you want to have an aggregated understanding of how well the movie is performing
or rather I can say the aggregated sentiment. So how do we do this? Well IMDB has been kind
enough to provide a large database, around there are 50,000 reviews but we will be using
25,000 of them. So the 25,000 reviews, they have categorically classified each of those
reviews as positive or negative and that is what you are basically concerned with. How
much positive, how much negative can be I guess taken from the ratings but more importantly
we want to understand how well you are performing through the reviews because ratings can have
a different biasness altogether. So a lot of actual information even on Amazon for example
how, what are the different aspects that your product is performing well on is actually
available in the reviews and not in the ratings themselves. So you want to use the reviews
which is the gold mine of information and you want to be able to generate or build a
model that can actually predict over time or automatically predict whether particular
review is positive or negative and then people can use this model for other tasks.
So this is our overall task that you want to perform today. So we will start off with
the preprocessing pipeline now. So we have this function preprocess. So what does this
do? It takes some input x, what is this x? It is going to be some string. So it is going
to take this string and it is going to clean up the string. So how are we cleaning it?
Now remember IMDB is an online website and we download the data from there. So obviously
it is going to contain a lot of HTML content which is basically how data exists online.
So there are going to be HTTP different HTTP s for example here we have added HTTP s as
one of the criteria for removing. So if you find something like HTTP s plus which is multiple
s's or single s or just HTTP you want to remove that or rather we replace it with just a space.
Similarly you want to remove all of these characters. For example in HTML you have these opening
brackets and these closing brackets as well to denote HTML content. So we are going to
remove all of that by replacing them with just a space. Similarly we will also be removing
all of these extra s's that might be there. So there are a lot of times when the website
makes errors and these kind of errors are dumped onto the content. So you want to remove all
of that as well. And you can obviously go wild and add as many regular expressions as
required to remove or clean your data as granularly as possible but we will stick to this for
now. So once we have cleaned the data for the HTML tags and content we are going to reduce
the size of the data. Sorry we are going to remove the leading and the trailing spaces,
white spaces from your string and then return this string. So now your string has been cleaned
and stripped of all leading white spaces or any new line characters and so on which are
not viewable. So this is a pre-process function.
Next up we will go to some of the helper functions. These functions are not really required for
this particular session but I will go over them anyway. These are actually important
functions if you want to save your model or if you want to load your model. Rather this
is an old way so what people usually do is they take an object, whatever object it may
be. So Python provides this pickle library. So all this is doing is it is going to take
any object that you have and save it as is. So that next time you load the object it is
going to load up just the way you were running previously. So you can save anything, you can
save lists, you can save arrays, you can save dictionaries. In fact you can save PyTorch
models as well but that is not the recommended way but in any case you can do it in this
manner.
The idea here is you just open the file, you have a file, for example whatever file name
you provide. They are going to create a pointer to that file and then you are going to dump
that file. So whatever object you have you are going to dump that object into this file.
So here bw means write and r means read. So what is this b decided? b means binary. So
I like to save my files in binary format because they allow us to actually compress the object
that you are saving and it is also secure because no one can actually open and understand
what is written there. For example JSON files you can actually save them as text files but
then they can be viewed by anyone. So if you want that extra security privilege you can
actually convert your file to binary. So first of all what we do is we open up, we add a pointer
to whatever file you want, we want and then in that to that pointer whatever the pointer
is pointing we will save the object and then close that pointer. So that saves our file
and similarly for reading the file we again have to open a pointer to that file and then
we have to call pickle.load and this will load the model or object whatever it is in
that exact format as was previously saved by you and then you can obviously close the
pointer and then use the data or object whatever it is.
So next up we actually come to the data cleaning pipeline. So the very first thing that we
did was we pre process the data. So as you can see here we are taking the data frame
so we are expecting a pandas data frame as input to this particular function. So we take
this data frame and we apply the pre process function that we just had that we just talked
about. So this pre process function expects strings as you can see we are calling the
apply function of pandas and what this apply function does is that it takes this pre whatever
function that we pass and it will apply to every single input where each input is a string.
So that is what we are going to do. So we are expecting pandas data frame which consists
of the text column and we are going to take that text column and apply this pre processing
function to clean our text or reviews of all the HTML content. So that is the very first
thing that we do here. Next up what you want to do is as sir has already talked about I
believe is the CLS and the SEP tokens. So the CLS token is the very first token that
we provide to the BERT model. So the BERT model expects a CLS token and a SEP token.
So what is this CLS token? I believe Sir has talked about this. So this CLS token is in
a way going to the vector representation of this token is going to contain all of the
sentence level information. So we can use this CLS token to actually perform classification
and ideally the CLS token should capture all the information about the entire sentence.
And it also marks the beginning of a sentence because every sentence begins with a CLS token.
So what we are going to do first is we are going to add the CLS token. So we add the
CLS token, we prepend it and then we take the remaining string whatever string we have
and we add to that. So what this means is basically we are concatenating the CLS token.
As you can see there is a space here as well. So we take the CLS token and we prepend it
to a sentence and where is the sentence coming from? As you can see the sentence is coming
from the data frame dot text column. So now all our sentences with the CLS token is contained
in the sentences variable.
Next we come to the labels. So obviously we need the labels as well which is either positive
or negative. So it is a binary, it is going to be a binary classification task. So that
is what we have done here. So we are taking all of the labels from the data frame. Now
our labels and our sentences are divided into the sentences variable and the labels
variable we do not really need the data frame now.
So now we move on to the model specific processing of the data. So if you remember when I was
talking about different models like BERT, T5, there are the models as well. What these
models do is that they expect their input to be tokenized in a certain way. So what
is tokenization? It basically means breaking down your words or basically you take a string
and you want to tokenize it. It means you want to break it down into tokens or what
are tokens? They are the basic unit of a sentence. Now there can be many basic units, many different
types of basic units. For example you can take a sentence and you can break it down into
words, individual words. How would you do that? You can do it based on space. There
are a lot of sophisticated libraries out there that break on a lot of other things. For example
you would not always have very clean text. You might have words that are actually joined
together. You do not have a space in between or you have a word with a full stop. Then
you might have some quotation marks and so on. So there are a lot of sophisticated tokenizers
out there that actually break down your sentences into words, quotations, full stops and everything
else. But that is the basic, you can always select a single word as a base unit or as
a token of your entire sentence. Or you could also break it down into individual characters.
So you can always break it down into each alphabet. For example the word fox, you break
it down into f, o, x and all of these would become tokens and so on. So as you can imagine,
if you break it down into words, you would have fewer tokens. If you break it down into
characters, you would have a large number of tokens. And then there is something in between
which is called subword. So why did this come into the picture? Well, let us go over the
history of it. So if you look at words, words can have a lot of spelling mistakes or there
can be a large number of words. Now for example, if you take the English dictionary, there
are probably around 900 or 1000 words, probably more. I am not really updated with that fact.
But there are a lot of words in the dictionary. So if you break our sentences down into words
and remember that later on, when we are working with the model, you probably remember that
models do not work with text exactly. They do not work with strings per se. But rather
we need to convert these strings into vector representations. Now as you can imagine, I
think sir also talked about this. Each vector is probably of size 768 dimensions. I assume
a floating representation that comes to 8 bytes, 8 bytes of information per dimension.
So that is 768 into 8 and then there are probably like 10,000 words or something. So if you
multiply that with that number of words, you can actually imagine how large the vector
representation becomes. So we do not want to work with such a large dataset. What you
want to do is you want to reduce it further. So now how can we reduce it further? Well,
you can always break it down into characters like f, o, x because as you can imagine there
are only very limited number of characters. For example, alphabets and then there are some
alphanumeric characters as well. But now the problem is taking you would have
a large number of tokens. So for example, if you are reading let us say a book, a book
might have let us say around somewhere around 20,000 to 30,000 words. But now if you break
it down into alphabets, now your tokens become way over a million. And reading all of that,
keeping all of that context contained is very difficult for any model. So we want to come
up with a middle ground somewhere and that is where the idea of subword comes in. The
idea is that if you look at the word going, you might see the word go which is go and
ing which is another word. Now the idea is going is composed of the subwords go which
is again another word and then ing which is utilized in a lot of other words as well.
For example, forgiving, running and so on. So the researchers came up with the idea that
you want to break this, if you break the words down into these subwords, a lot of these subwords
are unique and you can actually use them to build other words as well. So the idea that
was used in BERT and a lot of other models as well is this subword tokenization. So what
we will be doing is we will be taking these words and breaking them down into subwords
and coincidentally turns out that you do not need that many subwords actually.
For example, BERT is trained I think on around 30,000 tokens which is around 30,000 subwords.
So there are different models like for example, recent models come have their own tokenization
techniques. So what hugging face has done is that it has provided us with the tokenizes
for each model. So every model, not every model but quite a few models have their own
tokenization system. So what hugging face has done is that along with the model they
also provide us with that particular models tokenization system. So this auto tokenizer
class, this is a wrapper built on the entire or of the tokenization classes and it actually
when you pass the for example here, when you pass the model name what it will do is immediately
find the corresponding tokenizer and it will bring and it will give it to you in the tokenizer
variable. So the auto tokenizer is a very nice functionality that we have.
Next up what we are going to do is once we have the tokenizer for BERT in this case BERT
based uncased model, we are going to use that tokenizer to obviously tokenize the sentences
which is contained in the sentences variable. So now our words have been broken down, our
sentence has been broken down into different words.
Now if you remember as we have talked about, so this should actually been opening and closing
brackets. So as we have talked about the CLS is the opening for a sentence and the SEP
is the separator or the end of a particular sentence, it marks the end of a particular
sentence. So why is this important? If you remember when you are training on the GPU,
the GPU expects data to be of the exact same size but that is not the case for sentences
or for text input. You can have maybe a thousand word sentence or a paragraph, you can also
have a hundred word paragraph.
But now the thing is our model or PyTorch expects the GPU expects these inputs to be
of the same size so that processing can take place accordingly. It can be a fast, we can
process quickly. So if you want to do that you need to add padding. So what is padding?
So the idea is we, let us say we decide or conquer on a certain number of words which
make up a paragraph. For example, you can understand that when writing a review, people
usually start by giving some introduction about themselves and most of the information
is available either in the middle or the end or maybe you can think of it in a reverse
manner as well that most of the information is available at the beginning until the middle
portion.
So in any case whatever idea you have, whatever domain knowledge you contain you have, you
can use that information to limit the paragraph size. So certain paragraphs that are over
let us say in this particular case we are utilizing 140 words or sub words. So whatever
sentence you have has over 140 words, we will chop them off. So we will be using only up
till the first 140 words. This is for processing efficiency but it also is a lot of wasteful
information might also be removed or a lot of noise could also be removed in doing so.
So now you might have sentences that are longer than 140 but what about sentences that are
shorter than 140, what are we going to do about them? Well we will add pads or we will
basically add the zero character to it. So we can actually tell the model not to pay attention
and we will see about that later on but for now just remember that to make them of equal
size either we chop off a long sentence or we add zeros or what we call pads. So padding,
we will add that to the end of the sentence. So to make sure that when we have padding
to make sure that something else, the sentence actually ended and those zero characters are
not part of the sentence, we add the character sep and the sep token is actually used for
BERT pre-training as well because they probably sort of talked about this. They use two different
sentences and then they say whether this sentence entails the other sentence or follows the
other sentence or not. So they are using it for classification purpose as well.
So always remember that the sep denotes separation between two sentences or rather in this particular
case it denotes the end of a sentence. So that is exactly what we have done here, we
are saying that the maximum length of a particular string is going to be 140 words and then
what we are doing here is we are taking up till the max length minus 1 because you want
to include the sep token as well. So finally what we want to do is we now have tokenized
sentences of the same size as all of them of the same size. Now we want to convert these
tokens into numbers because these numbers are going to be used in a dictionary.
So the idea is that you have your string, you take your string and you map it to a number
and then that number will tell you what vector representation to look at. So we are going
to have a dictionary that is going to contain your word or tokens to numbers and then we
are going to have a dictionary which is also known as the embedding layer. We are going
to take that dictionary which is going to hold the id or the number and the corresponding
vector representation. So for that purpose what we need to do is we need to convert our
tokens to id which is again a very nice function that is provided by PyTorch it will automatically
do that for you and then we also add the padding. So we also add the padding which is basically
just 0 that is it.
Remember that these 0 characters are not really required we want to make sure that the network
does not involve this 0 character in performing any computations and what is the main computation
in any transformer model it is basically self-attention or the attention cross attention self-attention
whatever it may be. So we want to make sure that the model knows that these characters
you do not need to pay attention to. So what we do is we create an attention mask which
basically tells you it is either 1s or 0s so 1s would denote that you want to pay attention
to these particular characters so what we will have is let us say a long sentence of
multiple words and we convert those words into numbers so we have let us say 1, 20,
30, 33, 19 and so on and then we have lots of 0s. So what you want to tell the model
is for each of the numbers before the first 0 set them as 1 so now you have an attention
mask variable that has all 1s for the words that are involved in the computation and the
remaining portion that is going to contain all the 0 characters of the pads are going
to have 0 which means that you do not want to pay attention to these variables.
So this is the attention mask and finally we will be returning so we will be returning
the ideas that we just created the labels and the attention masks.
So what we will do is we can we will first run let us run each library and I would like
to show some what the text looks like. So let us run each of the cells until now that
we have talked about so this will take a bit of time to install because there are lot of
things to install along with these libraries a lot of dependencies actually.
You can also run these cells if you are following this particular session.
So in any case as the library gets installed we will go over the remaining portion of the
notebook. What I want to do is while we actually run these cells I would like to show what
the ideas look like and what the tokenizers look like and there are certain things that
I also want to talk about when we actually tokenize the sentence there are certain things
that you will find which are quite interesting. So in any case what we will do is we will
first load up the data. So we talked about the preprocessing now we come to the part
where we are going to load the data and then actually apply all the preprocessing that
we just talked about. So I believe the cells are done so we have installed all the libraries.
So we will load up whatever library we have. So again this is going to take some time so
again it is done actually. So we will move on to the next cell. So if we actually see
the device what is the device containing right now because we have a runtime which is T4 which
is the T4 I think this is the TPU. So if we run this device you will see that it is actually
device type is of CUDA. So we now have the CUDA or the GPU and we can run all our models
and all of our processing on the GPU if required.
So we will run these cells. Now we are going to load up the IMDB dataset we have the load
dataset functionality and what we will do is we will take the train set that we have
and we are going to convert it into pandas. So it is going to be converted into data frame
and we are going to do the same thing with the test partition of the data set as well.
So let us run this. So this green progress bar that you are seeing this actually comes
from TQDM. So TQDM again so it provides you with what is the progress of your loop and
what are the iterations, how fast they are running and so on.
So now we have our data. So what we did was we wrote display dftrain.head. So what this
will do is take the training portion of the dataset and it will show few rows from there.
So we can see there are a lot of different reviews I rented I am curious yellow. So curious
yellow is another probably a movie that was seen by people. I am curious yellow is again
someone talking about that and so on. So as you can imagine we have a very bare bones
preprocessing pipeline where we are removing where we are only picking the first 140 words.
But as you can imagine people are actually they start by talking about how they rented
the movie or where they went to watch the movie and so on. So these are not really information
that is required to understand the sentiment of the reviews. So maybe what we could have
done or you could actually try out later is that instead of taking the first 140 you take
somewhere from the middle and then you decide where you want to do, where you want to take
from somewhere from the middle so that you get those 140 words are the exact information
that is required and not just noise. So now what I would like to see is what is
the size of this dataset. So we can see that by running the len command. So as you can
see there are 25,000 training files and what are the number of test files? Let us see what
are we calling it DF value. So we have 25,000 validation or test files as well.
Now you can see in the data itself there are lots of stars here right. So we want to remove
all of this and this is where the where our preprocessing pipeline comes into the picture.
So we are going to run the cleaning pipeline that we just talked about. We are going to
do it once for the training and once for the test datasets. So what are we going to get
in return? It will be the IDs, the labels and the masks. So before we run this let us do
something. So what we will do is we will take these sentences, let us pick one sentence
and we will see what the sentence looks like. So let us say data frame we are going to take
the text portion and we will see what the sentence looks like before we call the preprocessing
function that we have and after the preprocessing function and let us call it quit for now.
So this will basically stop the execution of the code and we can just look at what the
lines look like. So we will run this cell again and let us try this out.
So you can see we have the very first sentence that we have is the non-pre-processed or raw
data. So you can see there are capitalizations and there is a lot of capitalizations and
because we did dot lower we call the dot lower function. So now we have the sentences in
lower case. So let us see what the sentences look like.
So I guess in this particular situation there is not a lot of cleaning that is required
here because I do not see any HTML content. So let us just go over and see. So there is
not much HTML content.
So here we see a little bit of HTML content and you will see what has happened here. So
these BRs they basically are your break statements. So just like your backslash in string content
similarly on websites you have BR which basically tells you which talks about the break statement.
So again we wanted to remove all of this. So as you can see after married men there is
a full stop and we directly begin with what we have removed these things because we do
not actually require them. So our pre-processing this pre-processed function is successful.
So now that we have this we can remove. So we will be pre-pending the CLS not really fun
but yeah what we want to do is we want to look at what the tokenized sentences look
like. So let us check this out.
So let us see what the tokenized sentence looks like. Oh so I guess our session has
restarted on collapse so we will have to run this all over again which is unfortunate.
This should be a lot faster now. So that cell is done. So we have run these cells let us
quickly run them over. Now we will look at what the data looks like. So it is going to
download the IMDb data set once again. So now we have the data set. So let us look at
what the tokenized sentences look like. So what it is doing right now is actually downloading
or rather what this progress bar is doing is actually running through this entire. So
this tokenization is happening. So it is running over the entire tokenization. So it is giving
us a nice progress bar. So now we can see what the data looks like. What the tokenized sentence
looks like. So we have the CLS token pre-pended. Then if you remember the sentence I rented
and I am curious yellow from my video store. So you can see that each for example here
I is one particular character or one particular word rented becomes another word and so on.
So we can ignore the error message right now. It is not really required. So here is something
interesting. So what you see is that for example usually under and then there is funded. The
word funded has been broken down into these hashtags. Hashtags and then you have the word.
So what this tells the model is that with these hashtags it means that these words
are sub words. For example under is an entire word in itself. But funded has been broken
down into f u and then n d e d alright. So to denote these sub words we have these hashes.
So you have double hashes to denote these sub words. This is what I wanted to show you.
So you will actually find this a lot in across the entire sentence. So for example den and
beri. So you can imagine if there was a word like den beri then it was broken down into
the sub word den and the word beri which again in themselves are actually words.
And there are a lot of other areas where you can see them as well. So that is something
that which I wanted to show you guys. So we can remove this and once we have our so we
now have our tokens what we want to now see is what those tokens look like for each sentence
in terms of words or IDs. So let us look at them. So we will again tokenize the sentences.
So we will look at the first tokenized sentence and then what we will do is we will look at
the IDs alright. So let us look at the first ID and we will return here
rather if you do not want the error that we got what we can do is we can return an umpire.
So let us run this again. So this will tokenize all of the sentences once again and we will
do it one more time just to you know make sure that we see all of the things that are required.
So this has printed out the tokenized sentence as is. And now you can see what these words
have been converted to the specific ID. So CLS ID is 101 the word I has the ID 1045 rented
as the ID 12,524 and so on. So now all of these words have been converted into the corresponding
numbers and then we will be going to use those numbers to take the corresponding vector representations
and then train the model. So the vector representations also get trained. So each word is going to
get their own learned vector representation right.
So finally we are done with our preprocessing pipeline these are certain things that I wanted
to show you if you are if you have the notebook you can actually run each cell and follow
along. So we will tokenize again just to make sure that none of those 0s are there that
we were just returning. So this can run for now. Now we will move on to the data loader
section. So now in the data loader section what we will be doing is we will be taking
the preprocessed data that we just have and we will be converting it into data set and
then into the data loader. So what is this data set? It is a simple wrapper that basically
allows you to fetch it is an iterator that allows you to fetch samples from whatever
data that you have. So this is PyTorch's way PyTorch's iterator that it utilizes this
underlying functionality we call it the iterator which basically iterates over your data and
picks samples as required. And what is the data loader? The data loader takes this iterative
data set and then breaks it down into chunks. So the iterator picks one sample at a time
when the data loader calls for a particular sample it will pick that sample and it will
it will provide it to you and then the data loader will take all of those multiple samples
and build a batch for you and then give that batch to you.
So that is what the entire idea here is. So the tensor data set it is again a nice class
that is provided by PyTorch where you can pass your whatever variables you have and
it will convert it into a tensor data set. And then you can use this you can pass this
data set to the data loader where you can specify what is a batch size whether you want to shuffle
it or not number of workers and so on. So we want to separate data loaders one for one
where the shuffle is false and one where the shuffle is true. So that is what we have done
here.
So now that we have a data set so as you can see we each sentence or each sentence is of
140 words. So we have made sure that all of our sentences are 140 words and how many sentences
are there or how many reviews are there is around 25000 reviews. So we have exactly that
many IDs, labels sorry A masks and labels. So now we have generated the data loader.
Let us run this. So we have generated the data loader successfully. Now one thing to
remember is that this tensor data set expects all your variables to be of type tensor and
that is the exact reason why we converted our IDs, labels and attention masks to tensor.
So once we convert to tensor you can actually pass them directly to the data set and we
create a data set for you. Now why does PyTorch require this iterable? Why do we need this
extra step before the data loader? It is because the tensor data set or any data set custom
data set that you build in PyTorch using the data set class what it does is that it gives
you one sample at a time. So now what you can do is instead of sequentially fetching
your examples you can actually use the data loader to fetch multiple examples at the same
time. So ideally what we do is we run a for loop and then you pick a batch of samples.
So you will be going even if you pick a batch of samples you will be going one at a time.
But what PyTorch allows you to do is you can actually pick multiple examples at the same
time. So how do we do that? So you can call num workers. Sorry, so this will obviously
be in the data loader. So we can actually call something called num workers. And you
can set it to some values. I believe the default value is 0. As you can see it is being shown
here. The default value is 0 which means your text will be taken sequentially. But when
you set it to let us say some value let us say 4. So now what is going to happen is that
the PyTorch data loader is going to call the tensor dataset or the dataset class of PyTorch
at the same time. And there will be 4 such processes. So there will be 4 such calls at
the same time. So you are picking samples parallelly. And when you are doing that you
can obviously imagine how fast your training is going to be. Because now you are not limited
to sequential batching and sequential training. But rather you now have parallel processing
and parallel training. Now what we are going to do is we are going
to create the model. Now there are many ways of creating this model. I think we had talked
about this in the previous in some of the previous lectures that you can do either transfer
learning, you can do training from scratch or you can just use a pre-trained model as
this. So there are all of these 3 ways can actually be utilized to load your BERT model.
And how do we do that? So I have actually taken the time to add these comments so that
you know exactly how to load the model in which scenario. So for example if you want
to load the BERT model without any pre-trained weights. So in that case and you want to train
the BERT just you want to just train the architecture on your very large dataset.
Then ideally what you want to do is you want to load it without the pre-trained weights.
So how do we do that? Well hugging face provides you with something called the config file.
This config file basically contains it is a JSON file I believe it contains all of the
information that is required by the BERT model to build the BERT model actually. So you can
actually go into the config file and change certain things and your architecture would
end up changing. So if you want to load the pre-trained model what we do is we actually
load our own config file. So this comes from the BERT config we are loading from the pre-trained
model BERT base and case. So what this tells us is that you just directly want to load
the BERT architecture. So you want to use all the configurations that are required to
define the BERT architecture and all of that goes into the config variable.
So we can actually have a look. So let us comment out all of this and let us comment
all of the other lines. And let us run this and see what the config file looks like. So
you can see the BERT config has architectures BERT for Marceline because this is the model
that we have loaded and all of these different hyper parameters are what define the architecture.
So we have attention, probability, dropout, probability. So what this means is that when
you perform the self-attention if you remember we have the softmax variable at the end. So
now you have probabilities. So you can actually what hugging face of the official PyTorch
implementation does is that they add extra dropout on top of those probabilities. So certain
probabilities can be dropped out by a probability of 0.1 or 10%. Then we have for example, what
is the activation function used here? So the activation function is GELU. This is another
kind of activation function. Then we have different dropout probabilities. You can see
the hidden size is 768. If you wanted you can actually change the size of the, changing
this hidden size to actually come up with a different model. So let us try seeing that.
So we will run this again and we will print the model. So you can see we printed the configuration
file and then we printed the model as well. So you can see the embedding size over here
the vocab size is 30,522. This is our vocab size and each as I talked about earlier each
word has a corresponding 768 dimension vector representation.
So these are the word embeddings. Then we have position embeddings which is again 512
cross 768. So 512 here is the number of tokens that the BERT model expects. And then we have
the BERT model you can see the in features is 768 and so on. So maybe what we can do
is let us check this out. So we can go for config and because this is a dictionary. Let
us see if what happens if we change the size of the hidden, hidden dimensions. Let us set
it to 700. So I am doing this for the very first time. So I do not know. Let us see if
this runs or not. So as you can see this is actually given an error because what PyTorch
what hugging face is done is that they have made this BERT config file read only. So you
cannot assign any values to it. So this becomes a totally different. So it is read only and
it cannot be modified at runtime. So we actually cannot do this. So if you wanted to do this
you would have to create your own config file.
So in any case the idea behind this method of loading the model is to basically load
the model without any pre trained weights. This is how you would probably want to train
your model from scratch. But this is something probably we do not require at the moment.
Now if you want to load your model for pre training that is you just want to load the
model as is with the weights. So if you want to load the model with the weights this is
how you go about it. So right now what you want to do is you want to perform classification.
So PyTorch or hugging face provides us with this BERT for sequence classification class
that you can call and it will actually create the BERT model and then add a classification
layer on top. And we will see what that looks like.
So we have this. Let us print this out and see what happens. So it is downloading a few
things including the model weights. So now the weights have been downloaded. We can actually
look at the model and you will see that I think this is what Saraz also talked about.
We have the encoders and there are 12 such layers of the encoder and then because BERT
is an encoder only model. So once the encoders are done you can see there is something called
a BERT pooler. So what this does is it takes a 768 dimension vector which is from the CLS
token and then provides a 768 dimension on top. So you can imagine you have the BERT
model. You can imagine a black box and then finally from the CLS token you apply another
linear layer and then you apply tanh on top of it.
So now you have a 768 dimension vector and then you can see that on top of that we have
the 768 cross 2. So you have the BERT model we get the 768 dimension from there which is
the BERT pooler and then we apply tanh and then again drop out and then finally we have
the linear model which is the feed forward or the single layer perceptron and we apply
a matrix 768 cross 2 dimension matrix. So what this does is that it takes that 768 dimension
and then converts it into 2. So now we have binary classification task. So this is how
we are going to go about this particular problem statement.
Now for example you might also want to let us say replace the last layer. So maybe you
are doing some task and you do not have a binary classification task. You can have a
n dimension classification task or n dimensional classification problem. So for that purpose
what we will do is we can actually replace the final layer that we had. So the BERT model
then we had the BERT pooler and then finally we have the classifier. So we can access the
model.classifier in this manner and we can actually change the number of output neurons.
So let us check this out. So we need to print this as well. So this is the old model, it
has 768 cross 2. Now we have replaced it with the 10 dimensions or with 10 neurons in the
output layer. So we can see that it has now become 768 cross 10. So I hope this is clear.
But for now we just want 2 neurons in the output because it is a binary classification
task. Now you might also want to actually train some of the layers and or rather fine
tune some of the layers and keep all the other layers fixed or frozen. So for that purpose
what I have done or what you can do rather is you can run a loop through the model to
the model layers and then for example here I have said that if I find the classifier
layer or the BERT encoder layer number 9 or BERT encoder layer number 10, we are going
to set the param that requires grad variable to true. So what this does is that it tells
PyTorch that you want to train only these particular layers. So you want to compute the gradients
and update the layers or the parameters of these layers with those gradient values and
all other layers should have the gradient set to false. So no gradient updates will
happen here.
And finally we have also calculated the total number of parameters which is basically going
through the entire model and then wherever we have required grad set to true we are going
to add it. So param dot numal is a nice function that actually adds up all of the which tells
you how many number of elements you have in a particular tensor. So we are going to use
that to find the total number of parameters. So you can see that the total number of parameters
is quite large. I think it is about 14, I believe it is 14 million parameters, 14 million
parameters. So that is a pretty large model that you are going to work with.
So now that I have converted into back to true, so you can see the number of parameters
has slightly reduced. So now our data is done, our model is done, we will now move on to
the training portion and see what happens here. So training in Colab with this sized
model is a little difficult. So I would recommend it running on your servers if you have one.
But anyways if you want to run it on Colab you can actually reduce the batch size and
run it. So it would not be an issue.
So there are certain things that I would like to talk about. The first thing is that always
try to use the Adam W optimizer for your transform model. So it has been empirically shown that
the Adam W optimizer works really well for transformers. And what is this Adam W optimizer?
Well right at the beginning we had something called gradient descent or we have this stochastic
gradient descent optimizer. So what it does is that it randomly picks a batch of samples,
a mini batch as you call it. So it picks a batch of samples and randomly and then you
train on that. You apply gradient descent on that batch and train your model.
Then came Adam which basically has this idea of momentum and second order variable that
it uses to optimize your model. Then comes Adam W. So what Adam W does is that certain
researchers what they found was that the Adam optimizer had some issue in its formulation
for the regularization formulation that it had some issues in it. So what they did was
they fixed that problem and then they proposed Adam W which is basically Adam weight regularized
version of Adam. So that is what the W stands for.
So it turns out this by fixing that formulation they were actually able to train transformers
much better. And it works and Adam W works really well for transformers and also for
other networks in general. But I would recommend using Adam W because that is the recommendation
by state of the art labs out there. They recommend to use Adam W for transformers.
And whenever you are using Adam W just a few tips and tricks for training. So whenever
you are using Adam W or Adam in fact you want to use small learning rates. And when you
have very deep models as well you want to use small learning rates these are certain
tricks that you can use to quickly train your model. But if you had let us say an SGD optimizer
you would have to set a very large learning rate like maybe 0.1 or 0.01.
Then we have the cross entropy we are going to use the cross entropy loss and we have
the from torch matrix we are going to call the accuracy class and we are going to say
that is going to be a binary classification problem. So now what we will do is we will
train the model. So we are going to go over certain number of epochs that we have specified.
These two variables are basically going to save all the losses. And you can actually
maybe you know print them out and check them out on the mat plot labor C bond library or
favorite plotting libraries and see how the loss evolves over time.
Now the very first thing that we are going to do is we are going to set the model to
training. So model what model.train does is that it will make sure that your model is
in training mode that is all the updates happen because in model.eval drop out batch normalization
all of this is stopped. No updates happen there. So you want to make sure that the model is
in training phase and all the updates happen. So what is something that you require here?
So for each in each epoch you will be iterating over your entire data batch by batch and training
your model. So in each patch what do we have? We have the IDs, we have the labels and we
have the attention masks. And we are going to pass all of this information to the but
for sequence classification model. So the first thing that we do is we remove all of
the gradients that might be on the computation graph then we move on to the we actually take
up all of the IDs, the masks and the labels and we are going to convert them into onto
the GPU. So all the data always is initialized and exists on the CPU. So we need to transfer
them to the GPU and then all the training happens and is transferred back to the CPU.
So that is why we need to make sure that all our inputs are actually moved over to the
GPU. If you see we have actually done that for the model as well. So we have done model.to
device. So we are going to do that here as well. Then we will perform, we will pass the
data to the model. So we are passing the X IDs and the attention masks and then we are
going to update our predictions with the predictions and the labels that we have.
We calculate the loss which is based on whatever output our model produces. So birth or sequence
classification that this particular model the way you access the output of the model
is by taking the preds. So the output will be in softmax, the softmax version we do not
actually need the softmax because cross entropy loss already handles this first. So the cross
entropy loss expects the raw values and not the softmax or the probabilities. So the raw
values are called logits and you can access them by typing preds.logits because the preds
is where all the predictions of the model exist. So we pass the loss, in the loss function
we pass the raw predictions by model and the labels.
And then we obviously save the loss and we calculate the, we compute the gradients and
then we update the gradients. We do the exact same thing for the test data set as well or
the validation data set. We first set a model to eval mode. So by setting a model to eval
mode will allow us, will make sure that batch normalization and dropout such layers are
not updated. And then we are going to run through all of this but obviously we do not
need to update the loss and so that is exactly what we are doing here. We are not updating
the loss values by running loss.backwardoroptimizer.step. So this is the overall picture. So you
can actually run this and this is training relatively faster because we have a T4 GPU.
I think this is the TPU or yeah, it is the GPU. The GPU is there. So it is going to train
pretty fast. So it is going to take some time to train but yeah, this was basically the
overall notebook and you can actually modify this and you can do a lot of things for example
as I talked about changing where you want to take the reviews from say you get better
classification accuracy, you can do a lot of things, better preprocessing, maybe changing
the dimensionality of the BERT model by loading your own configuration and seeing how that
performs and so on. So there are lot of directions that you can go with. Yeah, so I hope this
works out. Thank you.
We can move on to the questions that if anybody has. So the question is pre-training decoder.
Will it have sequential steps as it has a feedback kind of approach between layers. Yes, so it
has a sequential step. So when you are training, if you look at all of that logic, how the
data is passed through the model exists in the forward pass. So if you open up the source
code of the decoder, you will find that if you want to understand that logic, you can
actually go and look at the forward pass of the model and you will find that it goes through
the model sequentially. So yeah, the decoder part is the data is forward pass in a sequential
manner. Next question. Right, so the question is could you please explain how we are reaching
a binary classification task after using TANH in BERT puller. So let's go back to the model.
So as you can see, the BERT, what the BERT model does is after the final layer, right.
So after this, so there are around 12 BERT layers, right, which is the BERT encoder layers.
So after the final layer, each token has its corresponding vector representation as output
and I think Sir had talked about this. So each after the final layer, each word or each
token has its own vector representation. So if there are 512 tokens, then you would have
a 512 cross 768 dimension matrix, right. So now what you want to do is you want to take
only the CLS token because as I talked about previously, all of the sentence information
is said to be contained in the CLS token. So what BERT puller does is that it takes
from out of all of these vector representations at 512 cross 768 vector representation, it
takes the CLS token vector representation and passes it through a linear layer which
is just 768 cross 768. So out of that entire 512 cross 768, we take the first one, so
that is just a 768 dimension vector and we run it through a single, we multiply it through
a matrix which is of 768 cross 768. So you get a vector of dimension 768, right.
Now you apply tanh on top of that. So applying tanh just means that you are normalizing your
values between -1 to 1, okay. So if you look at the logit output that you get, it is supposed
to be between -1 to 1.
So now you have the 768 dimension vector which is basically a non-linear transform version
of whatever CLS vector representation that we had and then again on top of this, we are
going to apply another linear layer which is of dimension 768 cross 2. So again we are
going to multiply this 768 dimension vector with a matrix of dimension 768 cross 2 to
give us the two neurons or two outputs, right.
So now we have a two dimension output which is basically a binary classification problem.
So now either, so if let us say it is class 1 or output would be 0, 1 and if it is class
0 or output would be 1, 0. So whatever index is the highest value will be considered as
that particular class. So if the index 0 has the highest value, it is a 0.9 and the other
has 0.1 then index 0 is going to be considered as class 0.
Similarly, if index 1 has the highest value, let us say 0.7 then in class 1 will be considered
as the output of the model. So that is how we are converting the BERT model output to
from BERT pooler right up to the classifier layer. Next question. So that is all the questions
there were. So thank you so much and I hope you have, thank you for participating in the
session. I hope you have a nice weekend. Thank you.